Hi, I'm Alex
Cookson and I'd like
to talk about the power
of great datasets.
I'd like to start off this
talk by posing a question
that I think all of us have
asked ourselves at one point
and that is, how do I learn
to do this thing in R?
Whether that's sentiment
analysis, or data
visualization, or web scraping,
how do we learn something?
And Allison Horst who does a
lot of wonderful illustrations
about R and statistics has one
that answers this question.
And it shows how teachers,
mentors, and the wonderful R
stats community all
contribute to taking someone
from being a beginner to
some level of proficiency
with something.
But I always look
at this illustration
and ask myself, what
about great datasets?
Now when I say
great datasets, I'm
talking about something
pretty specific.
I'm talking about datasets that
are both cool and interesting.
And when I say cool,
I mean something
that when you come across
that you say to yourself, hey,
that's cool or
that's really fun.
It's something that speaks
to you on a deeper level
and it tends to be
pretty personal.
So what's cool to you
might not be cool to me.
And when I say
interesting, I mean
that it rouses your curiosity.
It makes you start asking
a whole bunch of questions
that you really
want the answer to.
If you ever played a video game
where you say to yourself just
five more minutes
or one more turn
and you're still playing
it an hour later,
this is the dataset version
of that, just one more graph.
So some examples that I enjoy
are the Duke Lemur Center
dataset which looks at
ages and weights of almost
30 different species of Lemur.
The Broadway Grosses
dataset which
looks at weekly box office
grosses, tickets sold,
average top ticket
prices of Broadway
shows going back to 1985.
And fictional
character personalities
which I consider to
be one of the all
time greatest of great datasets.
And this one looks
at personality traits
of 800 fictional
characters across over 250
different spectrums, such as the
playful to serious spectrum,
where we might find Michael
Scott from The Office
on the playful side,
and Worf from Star Trek:
Next Generation way over
on the serious side.
And I think this is
such a great dataset
because I've been watching
so much TV and so many movies
lately that when I came
across that I thought, Oh,
this is so fun.
It's something that
speaks to, something
I've been spending a
lot of my time doing.
And I immediately had
tons and tons of questions
that I wanted to ask it and
uncover from this dataset.
One of those questions
was, what are
some of my favorite
characters personalities?
And I put in a
whole bunch of work
and ended up with
some graphs that
looked like this which takes
the six characters from Pride
and Prejudice and shows
their strongest traits.
So we see that Elizabeth
Bennet at the top left
is a treasure as
opposed to trash.
She's important,
she has a high IQ,
she's independent, and
beautiful, and a feminist.
But to put this
together, I had to learn
to do a whole bunch of things
I didn't know how to do before
like use custom fonts so I
could get this Georgian era
kind of handwriting
vibe, to tweak labels
using the glue and
ggtext packages,
I had to choose an appropriate
color palette for the subject
matter, and adjust a ton of
theme elements using ggplot2.
A second question I had
was, which characters
are most similar to or
different from one another?
And again I put
in a bunch of work
and ended up with
something like this,
which looks at reasonable
versus derange characters,
plotted against rugged
versus refined characters.
So here we see that characters
like Sandor Clegane and Jayne
Cobb are really
similar to one another.
They're deranged and rugged.
And their opposites are
Charlotte York from Sex
and the City and Annie Edison,
who are reasonable and refined.
And to do this, I had to conduct
principal component analysis
with tidymodels because
these are actually
principal components, you
don't find them in the data.
I had to learn to add
text and arrow annotations
to get this graph here and
I wrote a blog post where
this is an interactive chart.
So I had to learn how to make an
interactive chart using plotly.
And if I can be honest
with you for a moment,
I never would have
put this much effort.
This many hours into
analyzing Titanic passengers.
It was because it was such
a great, engaging dataset
where I had tons of
questions that I wanted
the answers to that I had
the drive and the curiosity
to actually get those answers
and learn a whole bunch
of stuff in the process.
So I encourage you to get
your own great datasets.
And to Allison, I
very respectfully
think we may add one
thing to the balloon.
Thank you.